humanity struggle against death has been
our most enduring fight
history has given us one weapon in this
existential battle we fight back with
medicine tens of thousands of years ago
our ancestors scavenge to the natural
world for remedies imagine the
incredible leaps of faith we had to take
in an effort to ease the pain mend the
broken revive the sick medicine was a
dark art full of false starts and false
gods but when we struck upon some form
of relief it's swept like wildfire
through humankind we built on every
success until medicine became a form of
science that's when we discovered the
real killers within us microscopic
armies hidden within our bodies waging
war on our species for thousands of
years
medicine is our great weapon to fight
back against invisible unthinkable death
[Applause]
from superstition to science medicine
has become one of humanity's most
powerful tools and go with each new
challenge we may stumble find a way to
get stronger and smarter to be back
fatal diseases and extend our lifespans
even crack open our genetic code
this is the story of how our fight
against death has determined our fate
how it became the driving force of our
evolution
how are tireless pursuit of Medicine has
made us modern and even made us
superhuman this is origins
[Music]